it's a dance steps to four which is
really dense in here does it not say on
here
like how big it is
222 Acres that's big yeah that is kind
of big isn't it it is because when you
think of the farm where I live and the
75 Acres where Matt lived or well he has
it all now
um that's a hundred well we kind of need
to talk to them about pumpkin seeds and
whether we're going to be a part of it
yeah before I commit to that or figure
that out
um I I gotta get my head around it well
I've been thinking about pumpkin season
because I know it's coming up here
sooner than later and obviously the
north side part of it is up for sale so
I don't know I just have to have a
little bit more info as to what does
this year look like what's changing you
know what are the tours what is his game
plan you know he asked me to do a tour
that he had forgotten about and stuff
and I said sure you know I'll go do it
we also heard from Matt that his dad had
to go in the hospital and he had a tour
a private tour scheduled on the farm so
you know I definitely said yes right
away because you know he's in Arizona
attending a family matter and you know
you you just help out regardless of
what's going on you you it's just what
you do
but I tell you I said yes way too quick
because I was like
okay what do I talk about now
it's been quite some time since I've
done a tour ever since I've moved off
the farm I kind of like feel
disconnected last year was my first time
doing the wagon tour first time I ever
participated on any part of that and I'd
definitely be open to doing it again
obviously this is our big pumpkin area
we've got uh several varieties of
pumpkins to choose from is a pumpkin a
fruit or a vegetable
[Music]
have you read the script
we just tweaked and critiqued him a
little bit but so harsh I was not he
might have had a little rough start but
he he did fantastic the rest of the time
yeah if Matt needs help with you know
tours you know depending on what the
tours look like I'd be happy to help out
but
um
yeah I'm not sure I it's pumpkin
season's lost its lure for me now
foreign